be careful in the kitchen tomorrow you  know there are three times more fires on  thanksgiving day than any other day of  the year stove fires in particular very  common obviously with all the cooking  firefighters say if there is a fire like  the one you're seeing there  try not to use water don't use it at all  instead place another pan on top like  you're seeing there to try and put the  fire out  also keep children away from the stove  when you're cooking  because kids can reach up and get a  handle pull something hot down on  themselves so again make sure you're  supervising your kids around and kind of  cooking that's going on during the  holiday season  experts say never leave a stove  unattended just you just heard they add  save the wine for dinner maybe not while  you're cooking just so you can be  focused